[موسيقى]
تحت حراسه مشدده يدخل كيم سيبا الى القاعه
حشد متحمس يصفق لهذا الرجل الذي يقدم نفسه
على انه المنظر الجديد لوحده افريقيا
واستقلالها
سيكون القرن الحادي والعشرون قرن الوحده
الافريقيه داخل القاره وبين صفوف شتاتها
سنحدد الوقت في كل مكان حتى في هذا البلد
في افريقيا الناطقه بالفرنسيه يزدهر
الخطاب المناهض لفرنسا
باريس تخسروا مكانها هناك وروسيا تنشر
بيدقها
في مالي وبوركينا فاسو وجمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى سيطرت حكومات مواليه لروسيا على
السلطه من خلال الحروب والانقلابات
الدعايه مستمره وبقوه في ظل المناوره تقدم
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه على انها منقذ
افريقيا
كيميسيبا و فرانك
مؤثرون يدافعون باسم الوحده الافريقيه عن
الحضور الروسي
اركعوا من فضلكم
تذكرون جيدا الدوره الايجابيه الذي لعبها
الروس في تحرير البلدان التي كانت تحت
العبوديه
منهم هؤلاء المؤثرون الافارقه المشتبه في
انهم يلعبون لصالح الكريم
مثقف ناشباب منشطات الافريقي قلقون على
مستقبل القاره ويبحثون عن قدوه
وجدت انه شخص لديه الكثير من الشجاعه شخص
تطرق الى اللب الموضوع وهو مصدر لالهام
الشباب المتحذر من اصل افريقي
لم اكن اعرفه في بدايته عندما كان مثيرا
للجدل الان ارى رجلا تغير بمرور الوقت
وبعد عده اختبارات على الشبكات الاجتماعيه
يدافع عن الوحده الافريقيه يتابعه حوالي
مليون وخمسمائه مشترك هدفه محاربه الوجود
الفرنسي في افريقيا
انه يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره بفضل طريقته
البسيطه والسهله في التخاطب مع نبره فيها
الكثير من التامر
في فرنسا اصبح كيم سايبه معروفا في بدايه
القرن الحالي هو مؤسس قبيلتك وهي حركه
راديكاليه مستوحاه من حركه الفهود السوداء
قدم له الفنان الفكاهي الفرنسي دو جوني
المثير الدائم للجدل من بره الاول في
ابريل عام 2006 وعلى موقع
المتهم بقتل ايلان حليمي
ايها الزنجي القذر سيهتم اليهود بامرك هم
من قالوا ذلك وانا اهددهم واخبرهم في حالي
لمستم شعره واحده من راس يوسف فوفانا سوف
نعتني بشعر حقامتكم قلت ذلك بعد شهر
اقتحمت مجموعته الحيه اليهودي في شارع
ليغوسي حوالي 30 رجلا اسودا يرتدون ملابس
سوداء لا يحملون اسلحه لكنهم يهددون بعد
هذا الحادث تم حل قبيلتك بسبب معاداه
الساميه والتحريض على الكراهيه العرقيه
ليجد كيميسيب مخرجا ثانيا في السنغال
استبدل الستره الجلديه بازياء محليه على
قناه اس اس تي في وفي ذروه ساعات المشاهده
تكلمك متحدث باسم مناهضه الاستعمار
ومكافحه الفنك الافريقي في 2017 احرق ورقه
خمسه الاف فرنك افريقي في ساحه عامه في
داكار ما كلفه الطرد من البلاد لكن الامر
لفه انتباه رجل ما زال حينها مجهولا في
القاره وهو
بعد عام من الحمله الاستثنائيه التي
خذناها ضد فرنك المستعمرات الافريقيه
الفرنسيه وقال لي انني اريد دعمك قال لي
من هم ضد اعدائنا هم اصدقائنا وبالتالي
فهم يدعموننا لوجستيا رئيس دعايه الروسيه
يقدم نفسه كراع لقضيه الوحده الافريقيه
وفقا لوثائق كشف عنها فريق من اتحاد
الصحفيين الدوليين استفادى بين عامي 2018
و 2019 من دعم مالي يفوق 400 الف دولار من
زعيم فاجنر اليوم ينفي الناشط صلته
بالمجموعه لكن اتصالاته مستمره مع روسيا
بالنسبه الى وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ما
زال كيميسيبا الى جانب سويسريه النتاليانب
بمثابه حلقه اساسيه في سلسله المعلومات
المضلله التي يرعاها
وتتم استضافته في المؤتمرات المنظمه في
موسكو
الجواسيس الفرنسيين والامريكيين الذين
تسللوا الى هذه القاعه يبشر هنا بنهايه
العالم مفهوم مهم بالنسبه الى
الكسندردوغين ومناظر الكرملين منتقد كبير
للقيام الغربيه التي يعتبرها منحطه يعدد
جين ايضا مرجعا لليمين الاوروبي المتطرف
بعد عشرين عاما من ظهوره الاول ثقل
كيميسيبا خطابه لكن اسوسه ظلت على حالها
عندما يتم القبض على يهودي حتى على كوكب
المريخ تعلمون كيف تتصرف الحكومه
الصهيونيه ولكن عندما يتم القبض على
افريقي ويتم الاعتداء عليه وضربه واختياله
ياتي رؤساءنا للاستفسار عن الوضع ومعرفه
ما اذا كان مواطنون لا يعانون كثيرا
[موسيقى]
لان كيميسيبا يستنكر ايضا اهمال القاده
الافارقه لمواطنيهم فهو يدعو الى انتفاضه
شعبيه
لنتكفل بالمسؤوليه ونتولى امرنا اما
افريقيا حره او الموت سننتصر
افريقيا الحره او الموت اشاره الى توماس
سانكر رمز الوحده الافريقيه
يبدو لي ان ايجاد اي تقارب بين توماس
سانكره
بمثابه الحاق الكثير من الاذى على شخصيه
توماس سنكره هو لم يكن داعما للوحده
الافريقيه عن طريق الكلام التعويدي
بالتالي كيف نتحدث عن رجل قاد بلدا والهم
اجيالا من القاده على نطاق قاره باكملها
ونقول ان وارثه هو كيميسيبا الذي ليس لديه
اي مرجع مؤسسي والذي لا يتحدث تقريبا اي
لغه افريقيه اعتقد ان هذا سيكون اهانه
للتاريخ
لديه القدره على التمثيل بعد 15 دقيقه من
الكلام غير فجاه هدفه
تلقيت معلومه استراحه قصيره قيل لي للتو
ان قناه فرانس 24
في القاعه
الرجل لا يخفي عدائه لوسائل الاعلام
الفرنسيه المتهمه بالتحيز
الرغبه في طردكم عظيمه لانكم لا تعطوننا
الكلمه ابدا لا تستضيفوننا ابدا في
منابركم لا تستضيفون الا السوده الموالين
لكم
[تصفيق]
اسود البيض عبد او البيت نعوت
الاتهام الاخرين عندما تذهب الى هذه
القنوات فهذا يعني انك تدافع بطريقه ما عن
شكل من اشكال انهزام مجتمعك وتغدر
بالوكاله هذه هي المشكله الكبرى تقريبا لا
يوجد اي شكل من اشكال التحاور الممكن
في وسائل الاعلام الروسيه على قناه روسيا
اليوم يتحدث المؤثر كاسياسي يدعم الشراكه
التي دعا اليها فلاديمير بوتين
ستكون روسيا شريكا مختلفا عن الاخرين
طالما انها تتجنب السلوك الاستعماريه
لاسلافها اعتقد ايضا انه من الضروري ان
يكون هناك نقل لتكنولوجيا صفقه مربحه
وشراكه مربحه
يظهر كيميسيب دعمه للانقلابيين الافارقه
الحلفاء الجدد للروس هنا مع السيمي جويته
قائد الزمره العسكريه الماليه وعلى هذا
المنبر يتحدث عن دوره في الاضطرابات
الجيوسياسيا الاخيره
لقد رايتم ان الامور في مالي قد تغيرت وقد
ساهمنا فيها بشكل كبير ورايتم ان الامور
تغيرت في بوركينا فاسو وقد ساهمنا مع هذا
الفريق بشكل كبير نوعا ما الان يهدد
الحلفاء الاقليميين لفرنسا ومنهم الرئيس
الافواري وقريبا قريبا الحسن وترى ستفهم
ايضا والرئيس السنغالي
قريبا اذا لم تترك عثمان سونكو وشانه
ستفهم ايضا
[تصفيق]
يقدمون انفسهم على المنابر كفاعلين
اساسيين كفاعلين في الاطاحه بالسلطه في
مالي وبوركينا وغيرها عندما نعلم ان
المسارات معقده اكثر بكثير من ذلك
ندرك ان الامر هنا يتعلق فقط بالترويج
لصور اشخاص وحركات على انها اكتسبت نفوذا
سياسيا كافيا للاطاحه بدول
بعض الاشخاص ثم نخصكم بعدها بالحديث
بعدها رفض كيميسايبا اجراء مقابله معنا
لكن مؤثرا اخر وافق على استقبالنا انه
فرانكلين يمسي الفرنسي الافواريه استاذ
فلسفه في فرنسا وهو ايضا معارض قوي للرئيس
الافوري الحسن وترى قبل خطابه المباشر ثقل
كلامه
[موسيقى]
اقوم بما يفعله فنانو الجاز لان لديهم
المقياس الاساسي للارتجال اتحدث الى هذا
الجمهور كما الهم
للرجل حوالي 630 الف مشترك على شبكات
التواصل
انه جمهور كبير نسبيا ولكنه ليس افريقيقيا
فقط
بشكل شبه يومي وعلى قناته على يوتيوب يسخر
من السياسه الفرنسيه في افريقيا
الحريات احييكم
كيف يمول الارهابيون انفسهم في افريقيا
هذا هو الموضوع الذي اود ان اتناوله
عاده ما ينتقد الصحافه الفرنسيه لكن اثناء
زيارتنا اختار مقالا منشورا على موقع قناه
هذا المقال هو ملخص عن تحقيق لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز حول تجاره الرهائن في منطقه
الساحل يعود الى 2014
نكتشف اليوم ان الجزء الاكبر من الاموال
الموجوده في جيوبهم تاتي اليهم من تجاره
الرهائن وان اكبر دافعي الاموال هم اولئك
الذين يقولون للافارقه انهم يحاربون
الارهاب الى جانبهم ام لا كيف كان لنا ان
نفقد 58 جنديا فرنسيا لقتال الارهابيين
الذين نحول لهم اكثر من 100 مليون دولار
بزريعه تحرير الرهائن هذا يطرح مشكله
حقيقيه اعلى الصفحات المواليه لروسيا تتهم
فرنسا بانتظام بتمويل وتسليح الجماعات
الارهابيه في منطقه الساحل
[موسيقى]
روايه قديمه جدا والروس ليس مصدرها
التغيير الذي حصل مع وصول الروس هو ان هذه
الروايه تتكرر بشكل منتظم قبل كل شيء يجب
ان نفهم ان عمليه التضليل او التضخيم هذه
تتغذى بكل بساطه من هذا الاحباط الحقيقي
وعدم الفهم الحقيقي لهذا النقد الحقيقي
للسياسه الفرنسيه تحتل الاخبار الروسيه
مكانه بارزه على الصفحات
يظهر تعاطفه مع الكسندر دوغين مناظر وجدنا
هذا الفيديو على منصه التواصل الروسيه
في ابريل من هذا العام نظم دوغين مؤتمرا
عبر تقنيه الفيديو وشارك فيه نيمسي اود ان
احيا البروفيسور واقول له لكم مني كل
المحبه والاعجاب افريقيا تحبه
ولا يخفي فرانكلين يمسي قربه من
اسيميغويتا قائد زمره العسكريه الماليه
وحالي فيغنر الجديد عند سؤاله عن انتهاكات
مرتزقه الروس يقلل فرانكلين من ذلك
مجموعه فاجنا المتهمه بارتكاب ابتزازات
عندما نقارنها بالابتزازات العنصريه
الاستعماريه ومناهضه الاستعمار تعتبر قطره
ماء في بحر من الصعب تحديد طبيعه الحقيقيه
للسله بين اليمسي وروسيا امام الكاميرا
ينفي بشكل قاطع انه في خدمه الكرملين
لم اذهب الى روسيا قط لا اتكلم اللغه
الروسيه لقد فهمت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
الرفض الذي تعرفنا له نحن الافارقه في
فرنسا لديهم نافذه جيده يكتبون لنا من
خلالها يراسلونني عبر البريد الالكتروني
ليخبروني انهم يودون سؤال عن مساله ما
في ابريل الاوقافات وزاره التربيه
الفرنسيه
فتحت له منابر لظهور كضحيه للدوله
انا ضحيه اضطهاد سياسي في فرنسا
لا يمكننا ان نقول انه بسبب انك مع خطاب
الوحده الافريقيه فانت مضطهد الجديد في
الامر هو ان هناك حربا اعلاميه وفي هذا
السياق تميل السلطات الفرنسيه الى الصرامه
مثلا ضد من تصنفهم كعملاء او مرتزقه في
هذا الاطار شخصيا اعتقد اننا نمنحهم
الكثير من الاهميه نمنحهم قوه مزعزعه
للاستقرار ليست لديهم
في الرابع والعشرين من يونيو عام 2023
قامت مجموعه من فاجنر بقياده يفجن بتمرد
فاشل في روسيا ليعلن الطلاق بين بوتين
هو ان هذا الوحش الذي خلقه بوتين وهو نظام
فاغنر نظام بريكوجين في افريقيا
ينقلب اخيرا ضد مصالح الكريم وبالتالي اذا
تحقق هذا السيناريو فهذا يعني ان الدوله
الروسيه ستضطر الى البحث عن منافذ جديده
للتاكيد
تخفي نواياها الحقيقيه ضد الغرب مع الكريم
يتمتع المؤثرون برعايه مزدوجه وبخطاب
الكراهيه المباشر يمكنهم التاثير على بعض
العقول